un site internet ukrainien pour rassurer
les familles des soldats russes la
guerre dure depuis quatre jours lorsque
les autorités ukrainiennes décide de
mettre en ligne des passeports et des
documents militaires trouver sur des
soldats russes présumés tués ou capturés
en ukraine dans une vidéo de
présentation sur la page d'accueil ce
conseiller du ministre ukrainien de
l'intérieur s'adresse aux familles des
soldats russes en russie
je sais que beaucoup de russes
s'inquiètent de savoir où sont leurs
enfants fils marie que leur arrive-t-il
par conséquent nous avons décidé de tout
mettre dans le domaine public afin que
chacun donc vous puisse rechercher
l'être cher que poutine henry à la
guerre
il demande aux familles des soldats
russes de faire pression sur leur
gouvernement pour mettre fin à la guerre
cette initiative à dimension humaine est
avant tout une arme psychologique bien
pensé qui rend les pertes adverse réel
et joue sur le moral des russes le site
contient aussi des vidéos de soldats
russes présumés faits prisonniers
nous nous sommes rapprochés de kiev
cependant nous avons été touchés par des
lance grenades
les troupes italiennes aux grains ce qui
cause
ensuite nos munitions se sont épuisés on
a commencé à battre en retraite et c'est
comme ça que j'ai été faits prisonniers
depuis le début de la guerre moscou
garde le silence sur ses pertes